[Music]
you know look over the last decade or so
I think the biggest shift we've seen is
sort of the final breakdown of the
traditional channel based structure the
way we tend to think about
communications as paid media earned
media owned media the sort of sort of
traditional siloed approach to
communications that we still hear a lot
from marketing textbooks in business
school and I kind of think I think what
has happened is the the process of the
twenty years preceding the last decade
was about fragmentation read new types
of channels satellite TV and mobile
networks and just as incredible
proliferation of types of content and
channels within the silos that left
people feeling like they had infinite
choice but left communicators feeling
like it was impossible to reach an
audience what social media has done
particularly Facebook and Twitter have
created a glue to knit all these
fragments back together into something
that feels like one big graph one big
network of content moving between
channels and unpredictable ways of
engaging with people in ways that we
can't necessarily predict of creating
more to directional conversational
dialogues and communication between
individuals and and the people that
we're trying to reach and inspire which
is new behavior for us it requires
marketers and communicators and
publishers to develop new skills like
listening right that we didn't used to
have to do right we just picked the
channel and we picked the right message
and we said something to an audience it
was mostly pretty passive and I think
this is the big shift in thinking and
the real challenge for a lot of
organizations is the world we are now
part of a graph with the people that
we're trying to inspire rather than them
being a stable audience that we're
trying to reach and us being in a stable
position as inspirer or publisher we now
have to participate in the system right
people create content we create content
they share content we share content and
that means that we have to think
differently about how we communicate how
we tell stories how much content
have to create we can't reliably predict
where that contents going to get
consumed so it's really easy to get into
a situation where if we're not really
clear about our values and our identity
and who we are and what we're trying to
achieve we're sort of our values and
mission fit as an organization it can
become really easy to sound
schizophrenic to the communities that
we're trying to engage and I think a lot
of organizations are still really
struggling with this transition it still
feels really unsettling to folks because
it means whole-scale changing of the way
we think about content and communication
and publishing even means different you
know different org charts rethinking how
we shape the organizations and design
and staff and how teams work together
and how people collaborate are all
different than they used to be and
that's still a change process that I
think a lot of a lot of us and a lot of
organizations are still working their
way through so when we think about
politics and we think about what's
changed in communications one of the
most important changes to the
communication landscape is the shift
from the necessity of being able to
listen effectively at scale right the
necessity of seeing the people that
we're engaging as relationships we're
trying to create and the necessity of
empathy and listening as part of
starting relationships is fundamental to
communication now rather than either
orthogonal or accidental or you know a
nice-to-have you know this is the
fundamental nature of many of the
communication mechanisms we use are
bi-directional now and that means our
habits have to change yeah I mean I
think one of the one of the great
advantages of digital technologies is
the capacity to listen at scale but
something that wasn't possible before
digital tools right the ability to to
take to use data and to use sort of
smart sort of tools and listening to
listening tools you know things like
radian6 and Crimson hexagon and there
are a lot of these platforms out there
for those sort of you see them mostly in
sort of Enterprise marketing spaces but
work really well in politics and social
good and these other places to get a
sense for what people believe in think
in social conversations because so
this conversation is happening in public
and so the question about listening is
mostly a cultural one right the tools
these tools aren't perfect and they're
not all you know some of them are pretty
expensive
so not necessarily the easiest things to
implement and building skills and hiring
people and thinking about this as a
skill set that needs to be part of your
team as part of this process but before
any of that is a belief that listening
is important but a belief and and
creating a culture where questioning
your own certainty and validating your
own certainty and putting the community
first in terms of how how you want to be
able to reach and inspire the people
that you're trying to engage whether
that's selling a product or trying to
win an election right these things are
this is just a function of how the
landscape works this is not particularly
partisan it's not particularly about
politics but it requires a cultural
belief in the value of listening which
is not something that that all leaders
come by naturally and I think part of
part of this is a discussion about the
value of empathy right and of the value
of really the necessity of understanding
the values and beliefs and emotions
behind what people value and believed as
part of building real relationships with
people and this is where again digital
tools make starting relationships with
more people easier but maintaining
relationships is still work right so
this is one of the great challenges of
large-scale community organizing which
is the things that we were able to do
particularly back in 2008 with the first
Obama campaign when we were sort of
shredding a lot of new ground just
because timing has a lot to do with the
success of a rain dance the that there's
it created the ability for us to have
millions of volunteers which we could
never have recruited without these new
plot
we just couldn't have had that many
meetings I just would have run out of
hours in the day and time in the
campaign and and it allowed us to
accelerate the recruiting process and
the engagement process by creating more
doors and more ways into the campaign
for more people but me making sure all
of those millions of people felt
valuable and heard and respected and
part of the process and enabled to do
good work that had value that was on
mission is an enormous commitment of
work and there are thousands of field
organizers in the Obama community who
did the work of supporting those
relationships and I think this is one of
the big shifts in thinking about from
audience to community right we're
speaking at someone and saying the right
thing to you at the right time in the
right channel is a very linear process
right this is traditional micro
targeting and marketing right I need to
figure out what you're listening to or
what you're watching so I can show you
the right message and you're just going
to consume it and it's going to change
your mind it's like this is a little bit
the sort of the magic Mad Men idea I
like the perfect dad
the perfect sort of great idea and there
is value to that creativity and content
is still super central to how we
communicate and how we tell stories but
the process is not that linear anymore
and so thinking about how we engage
people as a relationship we are building
over time rather than just a transaction
at a moment in time is this is I think
the starting point to start bringing
these other ideas into the conversation
about empathy and what you think and
believe and feel and listening to you
and people will tell you what they think
if you ask them this is the other you
know people ask a lot of you know how do
you know what people think and the
answer is in politics we knock on a lot
of doors and we have a lot of
conversations hundreds of millions of
them literally conversations where we
are asking questions and talking to
voters and asking what they think and
who they support and we keep all that
data it is a massive listening exercise
it's a massive exercise in is is our
view and vision for the
future compelling and is it getting
through are we making sense are we
reaching people and connecting with
people in a way that is relevant to them
or are we missing something and people
will tell you if you ask them it's not
actually that complicated it's just it's
hard to do at scale and this is
something that has to be stacked for and
the LAT the the piece of this that I
think if the first part is about culture
or the last part is about adjusting to
there is a misconception that you can
just start publishing and just create a
page no one could you know no one charge
or anything you just start doing stuff
creating content isn't free responding
to comments isn't free being careful
about the ladder of engagement you're
creating with people and inspiring them
and engaging with them and answering
their questions isn't free right that
requires teams and talent and energy and
commitment to creativity that you have
to pay for and that's a place the
staffing changes in the way this changes
the way we think about like
communications departments is pretty
profound
[Music]